le plateau de saclay c'est ce vaste
territoire au sud ouest de paris
bien connue parce qu'il est l'un des
grands poumon vert de la région
ile-de-france à 15 km du sud de paris un
territoire agricole verts entourés par
une ceinture d'urbanisation depuis une
cinquantaine d'années se sont installés
sur ce périmètre assez petit en réalité
à peu près 15 à 20% de la recherche r&d
publiques et privées françaises donc des
grandes institutions de recherche très
connu de tous le cnrs l'inra le cea des
grands établissements d'enseignement
supérieur et de recherche l'université
paris-sud l'école polytechnique hec lui
restait versailles saint quentin et des
grands centres de r&d d'ingénierie des
grandes entreprises renault thalès
danone eads sont ici et tout ça fait un
an semble absolument exceptionnel unique
en france ça c'est certain
probablement unique en europe par ses
potentiels
l'ambition c'est simplement de prendre
acte de ces potentiels et d'en tirer le
maximum de faire en sorte que tout cela
rayonne et créer un moteur un moteur de
croissance de développement d'économie
de création d'emplois de création de
richesse au service de cette partie de
l'île de france mais plus largement du
grand paris est sans doute de la france
entière puisque on a ici en réalité la
capacité de créer l'une des dix grandes
plateformes d'innovation au monde
l'un des endroits attractif pour tous
ceux qui ont des idées qui veulent créer
qui veulent développer et qui est qui
regardent ces lieux d'agrégation ces
lieux où se passent les choses à la
raison d'être de ce projet c'est cessez
donc l'innovation et donc il s'adresse
en premier lieu à tous les acteurs de
l'innovation
mais il faut aller plus loin il faut
penser à tous à tous les techniciens
qualifiés plus ou moins qualifiés kit
qui travaille ensuite dans ces secteurs
il faut penser à tous les étudiants même
j'ai envie de dire aux futurs étudiants
à ceux qui ont envie de faire de la
science de faire de la technologie
donc il faut qu'ils trouveront là j'ai
envie de dire un terrain de jeu
formidable pour développer leurs idées
rencontre et se croiser des talents
différents et être créatif tous ensemble
ce développement cette croissance elle
s'incarne par la recherche de réponses à
des grands défis sociétaux qui se pose
aujourd'hui dans le monde
ce sans doute probablement en partie
dans le projet paris saclay on trouvera
des éléments de réponse à des grands
défis que sont le réchauffement
climatique les maladies
neurodégénératives l'alimentation de 9
milliards d'êtres humains
la question de l'énergie propre la
question des déplacements etc etc
ici vont se trouver vont s'imaginer des
solutions avec la recherche amont et
puis la transition vers la recherche
avaler vers des solutions technologiques
qui sont à disposition du grand public